the cameras watch the kids i stopped
taking the credit knocking your dad i
bought the house next door what you
think the point of really being rich for
when you give them everything they only
want more kanye west drops a disturbing
new music video
just after his estranged wife's divorce
court win as kim kardashian is declared
legally single
it's a different experience for sure
after the judge made that ruling yay
took to instagram with this god sent me
from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
yeah the rapper is no fan of kim's
boyfriend his feelings taking center
stage in the music video for his track
easy claymation figures play out a dark
sequence of events including yay
kidnapping a bizarro world version of
pete
there it is
don't interrupt
just because it's
and it only gets weirder from there
yay buries the pink look-alike and well
turns the character into a plot of
flowers
the cameras watch the kids i stop
the video ends with a reference to skeet
yay's go-to nickname for the comedian
a title card reads everyone lived
happily ever after
then except you know who with the name
skeet crossed out
and finally jk he's fine
but back in real life the timing of
yay's video is hard to ignore
as we mentioned a judge granted kim's
request to be declared legally single in
court on wednesday
e.t was at the courthouse tracking the
latest shakeup behind the scenes
kanye already has a new woman in his
life his fourth divorce attorney
that attorney samantha spector made her
debut in court wednesday it was a
last-minute shake-up for the case kanye
fired his previous lawyer a day before
anything kanye hopes to get done today
e.t was also inside the courtroom as kim
testified via zoom and when the judge
asked about the well-being of her and
yay's four kids kim replied everyone is
doing okay and i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for the
judge followed up with more questions
asking if disputes with yay led to the
dissolution of their marriage
yes she replied then whether time and
counseling might save the marriage kim's
answer no
in another win her maiden name was
restored making kim kardashian west a
thing of the past
and while yay didn't appear in court he
did have some things to say telling e.t
in a statement quote i've asked my team
to expedite the dissolution of my
marriage to kim so i can put my entire
attention to our beautiful children
just
just do something for my heart while the
judge did infer these proceedings have
gained momentum this case is by no means
settled
the next court hearing is scheduled for
august 5th
you